pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le matin du samedi 22 avril alger
s'éveillait dans un spectacle imprévue
des unités de légionnaires et de
parachutistes occuper les points
stratégiques radio alger annonçait qu
l'armée s'est assuré le contrôle du
territoire algéro sahraouie
cette proclamation était signé du
général challe démissionnaire depuis
jambes une fièvre nouvelle star est
aussitôt d'une population qui souffre
toujours de la plaie mal fermée de
l'algérie française
pendant ce temps les événements en cours
et on apprenait coup sur coup
l'arrestation du délégué général le
ralliement d'oran l'arrivée de salan le
discours du général de gaulle
[Musique]
si déjà dans l'édifice du complot
certaines fissures apparaissaient la
foule algéroise on imaginait rien encore
quand le lundi 24
elles envahissent et le forum pour
acclamer les quatre hommes qui s'étaient
emparés du pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
pour ben ali compte de la délégation
générale il nous apparaissait charles
salle un jour elle est tour à tour il
s'adressait à la population lui répéter
les mots qui activaient saffier mais
derrière les applaudissements de cette
foule pouvait-on ne pas entendre l'écho
des paroles qui avait prononcé la veille
le général de gaulle affirmant
l'autorité de l'état dénonçant l'action
des insurgés dictant des ordres pour
arrêter le drame
c'est un signe avant-coureur
annonçait-il déjà les clips ce rapide
des triomphateurs du jour l'embarquement
sur les mentions de 6 ans libérable
qu'on n'avait pas osé retenir pouvait
marquer que les hommes du contingent
regardait avec défiance l'opération est
resté fidèle aux commandes dans l'est
brushing à paris l'assemblée nationale
réuni en séance extraordinaire pour
écouter un message du président de la
république s'unissaient à sa résolution
de briser par tous les moyens à
l'insurrection et à trouver les mesures
prises pour le faire et soudain en
quelques heures tout s'effondre et alger
la majorité des unités stationnées la
marine l'aviation refuser leur concours
au complot à l'aube du mercredi 27
tout était rentré dans l'ordre les
gendarmes mobiles réoccuper la
délégation générale abandonné par les
quatre généraux
les troupes fidèles avaient repris le
contrôle ayant fait quatre jours la
conspiration se dit levé d'un seul coup
devant le refus à la fois de l'armée et
de la nation
[Musique]
dernier à la porte de la prison de la
santé un petit groupe en attend une
voiture qui entre sans ralentir le
général challe s'est constitué
prisonnier
ses comparses ont disparu la parole est
maintenant à la justice
l'épreuve est finie elle a été dure elle
laisse des traces douloureuses mais la
france a gagné
[Musique]
dans toute l'algérie la restauration de
l'autorité s'est opérée sans retard dans
la journée même de la reprise en main le
ministre d'état chargé des affaires
algériennes monsieur louis joxe
réinstalle est à la délégation générale
monsieur jean morin ramener en avion
ville ça là où il avait été déporté
[Musique]
alger parcours une patrouille surveillé
par l'armée ont fait le spectacle d'une
ville comme assommés sortant d'une
aventure à laquelle elle n'avait peut
être jamais cru tout à fait dans son
immense immeuble garder militairement la
radio d'alger était redevenu france 5
et l'on voyait dans les commissariats
s'esquisser les premières remises
d'armes dont la récupération doit être
opéré sous réserve de perquisition
[Musique]
des terrasses on pouvait voir l'escadre
partie toulon mouillé au large
six bâtiments parmi lesquels le croiseur
colbert l'unité la plus moderne de la
flotte française et le porte avions a re
manche le colbert qui avait ramené à
toulon les cendres du maréchal lyautey
avait appareillé pour alger dans leur
même de l'accomplissement de sa mission
[Musique]
un dernier acte se joue est à zéralda
camp de repos où s'était replié le 1er
régiment étranger de parachutistes qui
avait été à la pointe de l'insurrection
le 1er rep demain n'existera plus de
zéralda bloqué par les unités du
contingent 60 camions ont emporté au
milieu des pétarades des fumigènes
l'unité rebelles jusqu'à sidi bel abbès
dépôt de la légion où elle sera dissoute
c'est maintenant leur triste où l'on
fait les comptes et où le destin
présente l'addition
ces hommes-là paieront leur folie ils le
savent ils l'acceptent ses commandes
vient de mourir
ce monde où un ordre devient une base de
discussion
il n'y a plus aujourd'hui dans l'armée
place que pour une morale est une
discipline
à bord du croiseur colbert la dépouille
du maréchal lyautey à regagner la france
19 coups de canon ont salué le retour du
grand soldat qui sut de 1912 à 1925
créer les bases du maroc moderne et
faire d'une région un perpétuel état de
troubles un état solide et un pays
moderne dans quelques temps la france
donnera à lyautey la glorieuse
sépultures des invalides
il attendra ce jour émouvant dans le
silence de la petite chapelle de saint
mandrier sous la garde des marins qui
ramenèrent cessantes
[Musique]
le standing international d'une nation
dépend de l'importance de sa production
de la capacité de ses usines et du degré
de modernisation de son équipement
on a vu d'ailleurs quel chemin dans ses
divers domaines a parcouru depuis cinq
ans l'industrie française les industries
de base comme les cimenteries qui ont vu
depuis la guerre croître
considérablement les demandes en
fonction des besoins de la construction
doivent poursuivre un effort continu
d'investissement les prés du crédit
national concourant à leur financement
ces prêts qui s'adresse aussi bien au
grand complexe sidérurgique cas des
firmes modeste se répartissent
aujourd'hui entre plus de 2600
entreprises pour un total de 341
milliards d'anciens francs
il s'étend aux affaires commerciales de
toute envergure depuis le petit magasin
d'alimentation jusqu'au supermarché il
n'est pas de secteurs de l'économie qui
n'en ait bénéficié
si bien que le crédit national apparaît
comme le ressort de l'économie française
et plata font les bonnes soirées d'un
cirque espagnol la virtuosité avec
laquelle ils font usage de leur force
leur a d'ailleurs valu de solides
admiration la discipline musculaire de
ces deux athlètes au manu est telle que
les figures semble se suivre avec la
plus grande facilité
et pourtant
[Musique]
à notre époque de machines plus
étonnantes chaque jour il n'est pas
mauvais de se rappeler quelle admirable
mécanisme peut être aussi le corps
humain
[Musique]
claude condé est jaloux des lauriers de
grand-papa son grand-père était il est
vrai le célèbre matador de cordoue match
à quitte je n'ai pas toujours facile
d'imiter son drapé tous les jeunes de
villiers roos qui participaient à cette
course de taureaux vont avoir l'occasion
de s'en rendre compte
lequel d'entre vous va se décider
messieurs ne vous pressez pas il y en
aura pour tout le monde
surtout pas de panique il faut de la
dignité pour être un grand matador
[Musique]
oui mais un faux pas est si vite arrivé
le toro lui ne s'embarrasse pas de veine
fioritures
à ce train là on se demande s'il va
rester encore des combattants pour
terminer la corrida
et s'il n'en reste qu'un décidément le
courage ne paie pas
on finira bien par le 27 euros tout de
même
[Musique]
non ce n'est plus une corrida c'était la
potée
les femmes girafes vital de goualich les
a découvertes quelque part sur les hauts
plateaux de birmanie aux confins du laos
et de la chine
elles vont et viennent dans leur village
la tête posée au sommet d'une spirale de
métal leur coût peut atteindre jusqu'à
30 et 40 cm jadis ce collier vertigineux
servait dit-on à protéger de la mort sur
des digues
aujourd'hui il n'est plus que le signe
évident de l'élégance et de la richesse
l'une et l'autre se mesurant au nombre
des spires
à partir d'un certain âge l'abandon du
collier équivaudra à un arrêt de mort la
distension des tissus ne leur permettant
plus de soutenir le poids de la tête
ne croyez pas qu'une telle élégance vous
à l'oise yves t les femmes girafes
travail touchant avec peut-être
seulement un rien de retenue dans le
geste
[Musique]
oh
armure ou carcan ou bijoux ou les trois
en même temps comme le monde est étrange
disait déjà marco polo
en même temps il nous faut oui il nous
faut régler les affaires algériennes ce
qui vient de se passer a contribué à
démontrer que la seule voie pratique est
digne de la france c'est celle qui a été
choisie par le gouvernement adopté par
le parlement a approuvé par la nation
aux populations algériennes de prendre
en main leur destin à elle de décider si
l'algérie sera demain un état souverain
au dedans et au dehors elle aussi de
décider si cet état sera associé à la
france ce que la france pourra accepté
moyennant une contrepartie effective à
son concours et à coopération organique
des communautés quelles tâches fait
qu'on peut s'offrir dans ces conditions
aux algériens de souche française de
tout mon coeur je leur demande au nom de
la france et le jour même où nous
commémorons une victoire à laquelle ils
ont pris tant de part je leur demande de
renoncer au mythe périmés aux agitations
absurde d'une sorte que des malheurs et
à tourner leur courage et leur capacité
vers la grande tâche à accomplir
dans marrakech la vieille capitale du
sud le roi du maroc hassan ii a fait son
entrée solennelle comme il l'a fait
précédemment à casablanca et à fès ce
entouré de sa garde noire le jeune
souverain qui a succédé le 26 février
dernier à son père noam et 5 a reçu les
acclamations chaleureuse de la foule qui
se pressait sur son passage
des montagnes du haut atlas des trop
nombreux étaient descendus et le
pittoresque de la céder en rien à la
splendeur de la réception
jusque dans la nuit les réjouissances se
sont succédé faisant surgir des ténèbres
des tableaux colorés ou resplendit
toujours vivant l'âme à la fois poétique
et passionné du maroc
une tornade d'une violence inouïe s'est
abattue sur la normandie en pleine nuit
notre reporter a pu découvrir ces images
dramatiques d'une catastrophe qui s'est
étendue sur cinq départements et qui a
fait trois morts et des centaines de
blessés
[Musique]
m
le petit jour les routes de l'heure et
du calvados offrait des obstacles
imprévus des milliers d'arbres ont en
effet été abattu par le cyclone et dans
les faubourgs 9 d'evreux les immeubles
en construction se dressait au milieu
des débris parmi lesquels des grues de
50 tonnes qui aux dires d'un témoin
avait valser à 10 mètres de hauteur
partout des ruines des dégâts les
tristes méfaits d'un drame contre lequel
l'homme n'a pas de défense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quatre mille bâtiments sont plus ou
moins endommagés certains sont
entièrement détruits les toitures
arrachées ne se compte pas il y en a
trop pour des centaines de cultivateurs
c'est la ruine des centaines de familles
sont sans abri on reste atterré devant
les effets de ce phénomène métérologique
très rare dans nos régions
plus de 50 communes en effet on était
atteinte sur un parcours de près de 200
km un grand malheur pour la normandie
un deuil français gamme
à l'heure du festival mais cette année
le festival s'est assagi on parle même
d' austérité
[Musique]
toaster matin quand même pas le monde
entier
après donc le tour classique de la
croisette où l'on a croisé les grandes
vedettes et les petites le tour des
gloires du festival
probert de soi et grand décolleté entre
l'école des marins en visite
voici monsieur fourré cormerais
directeur de la cinématographie
française
bernard et annabelle buffet yves montand
et simone signoret torture gates
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et la plus attendue celle qui ameutent
les foules et suscitent les bagarres de
photographes social rennes l'unique au
moins jusqu'à ce qu'arrive brigitte
bardot
[Musique]
à cap canaveral
un homme dans son scaphandre pressurisé
alan chez pas l'ascenseur de la tour de
lancement la conduite au sommet de la
fusée tandis que les techniciens saluer
à l'américaine le casque sur le coeur a
pris place dans la capsule mercury
position couchée le mauvais temps avait
retardé de quatre jours cet instant un
incident technique allaient encore faire
attendre plus de quatre heures le
commandant shepard enfermé dans sa
capsule
9h34 la fusée redstone s'élève enfin
doute est-il impressionnant de penser
qu'un homme est enfermé au sommet de
cette fusée qui doit en 15 minutes lui
faire faire un bond gigantesque à 185 km
de la terre le porte-avions lake
champlain veille
ces hélicoptères ont la mission de
recueillir la capsule
la voici
[Musique]
après avoir ici à son bord le commandant
alan shepard l'un des hélicoptères
ramène les 1360 kg de la capsule
succès total alan shepard a sans doute
fait qu'un bon dans l'espace mais
l'amérique possède elle aussi son
cosmonaute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mora et ses petits marcassins les
mascottes de ceux d'enfants porté chance
à leur équipe en finale de la coupe de
france de football
les sedanais en manches blanches
rencontre les nîmois devant 45000
spectateurs à colombes 45000 spectateurs
qui vont en avoir pour leur argent
il assiste à une finale coloré où le jeu
pratiqué par les deux équipes et rapide
et à trier ce sont les sedanais les plus
dangereux au cours de la première tant
ils sont sur toutes les balles et la
défense nîmoise est souvent en
difficulté elle s'en tire à peu près
bien comme en ce moment et les sedanais
finissent par obtenir la récompense de
leurs efforts 1 0 à la mi temps
dès le début de la deuxième période de
jeu les nîmois appuyé sur l'accélérateur
et durant un quart d'heure ils occupent
le camp sedanais par vagues successives
on croit que nîmes va égaliser
une fois deux fois dix fois rien à faire
le ballon et capricieux et la défense de
sedan intraitable
ce qui n'empêche pas les avants
ardennais de tenter de temps à autre des
raids dans le camp nîmois où
manifestement on s'affole
résultat un deuxième but pour sedan la
victoire est proche
le troisième but ne va pas tarder les se
donnait n'en demandait pas tant et c'est
ainsi que more a pu faire son tour
d'honneur après la victoire de son
équipe sur nîmes par 3 buts à 1
les américains qui adore la difficulté
ont une conception très particulière du
motocross social paiement qui paraît
bien parti se doit d'être un spécialiste
du saut d'obstacles
poids pour forcer ces motos à monter les
côtes manifestement elle préfère les
descentes
c'est beau l'entêtement mais il n'est
pas toujours récompensée par le succès
[Musique]
à washington au côté du président
kennedy le commandant shepard a trouvé
la consécration de son exploit
[Musique]
le film pris par la caméra placée dans
la cabine permet de revivre tous les
instincts de cet exploit et en
particulier celui impressionnant de
l'apparition dans un hublot d'une sphère
à l'aspect taux monte à 180 km
la terre félicité décor est acclamé alan
shepard a vécu le jour de gloire d'un
héros national
[Musique]
en perdant gary cooper le cinéma perd
sans doute l'un de ces grands noms mais
le public des salles obscures pairs
comme un frère c'était en effet depuis
30 ans le cowboy bien aimé l'un de ses
héros auquel va tout de suite la
sympathie quand la guerre sur 20 il fut
l'un de ses artistes ambassadeurs de
l'amitié qui a l'air sous tous les ciels
soutenir le moral des armées au combat
c'est qu'il était le héros type de ces
épopées édifiante qui nous rendent pour
un jour la fraîcheur et l'enthousiasmé
de l'adolescence et il l'était avec
cette simplicité qui trouve tout de
suite le chemin du coeur il meurt à 60
ans après avoir tourné près de 100 films
il sera toujours le plus courageux des
trois lanciers du bengale toujours
l'adorable le modeste l'extravagant mr
deeds l'arrêt cooper est mort pas tout à
fait
[Musique]
la fièvre d'alger n'est pas apparente
mais dans le tort une partie de
l'escadre méditerranéenne avec le
porte-avions lafayette restent amarrés
tandis que de rigoureuses mesures de
sécurité sont maintenues et que 28 mille
hommes des forces de l'ordre mènent une
surveillance pour empêcher la
recrudescence des attentats activistes
paris n'a pas été épargné une flambée
d'attentats au plastique a fait des
dégâts et des victimes au palais royal
où les fenêtres du ministère des
affaires culturelles qu'occupe monsieur
andré malraux ont volé en éclats et
russie mot d'horreur à la porte d'un
conseiller municipal et où les criminels
ont signé leurs actes
[Musique]
en plein jour deux autres explosions se
sont produites dans le quartier de
l'opéra l'une rue des pyramides dans les
bureaux d'un journal et qui a blessé
deux passants une autre où l'on a relevé
cinq blessés avenue de l'opéra des
esprits fossé n'hésitent plus devant le
crime
c'est dans ce climat troublé que le
maréchal lyautey a fait sa dernière
halte sur le chemin du retour
le corps du créateur du maroc moderne à
passer sous la voûte de la rrq de
l'étoile sa première nuit de paris
le lendemain ils étaient solennellement
conduit jusqu'à cette nécropole des
invalides que la patrie reconnaissante
réserve assez grand soldat mais si noble
que puisse être le décor à faire
finalement assez simple l'esprit et les
actes de lyautey ne saurait être
ensevelies et le général de gaulle en
citant une de ses phrases prophétique a
su tirer la leçon de son oeuvre immense
il y a lieu de prévoir disait petit
quand un temps plus ou moins lointain
l'afrique du nord évolue et vivant de sa
vie autonome se détachera de la
métropole il faut qu'à ce moment là a
ajouté t-il et ce doit être le but
suprême de toute notre politique
cette séparation se fasse sans douleur
et que les africains continuent toujours
de se tourner vers la france
si l'histoire a failli ou veut du
maréchal en l'arrachant à cette terre
marocaine qu'il n'aurait jamais voulu
quitter la flamme qui l'animait et
vivante
l'exemple qu'il donne en reste dont la
leçon qu'il a légué demeure fait qu'au
27 années après sa mort années qui
virent se transformer de fond en comble
les conditions de son époque comme l'a
dit le président de la république
le maréchal n'a pas fini de servir la
france
les grands problèmes de l'heure ne faut
pas oublier les eaux et les pigeons à
paris par exemple sont un problème il y
a trente pigeons bien sûr ils ont des
amis plein de sollicitude et fanta ce
qui fait partie du pittoresque locale
mais un regard il faut tenir compte des
dégâts qu'ils causent aux monuments
vénérable dont ils sont devenus la plaie
quotidienne sans parler des injures
causés aux gloires nationales
on conçoit que les édiles se soit
inquiété de leur dégradation et est
tenté déjà dans exils et quelques-uns
mais ils reviennent
ajoutez à cela que les gardiens du
patrimoine national ne sont pas ça la
vraie les pigeons de paris aux gémonies
les automobilistes aussi et les amoureux
alors alors il s'est trouvé deux
vilaines âmes pour faire plus que
souhaiter leur disparition
la précipiter quelques graines
empoisonnées ont ainsi provoqué l'agonie
d'innocents visait
méthode qui soulève l'indignation des
amis des bêtes alors il n'y pas tant de
nice qui est-il lépi jeunes et les
sacrifie avec douceur c'est le terme
officiel limitera tôt londres où l'on
daddy jeunes des bâtiments publics d'un
produit qui éloigne les oiseaux ou bien
vienne ou passionnant des spécialistes
vont stériliser les oeufs dans les nids
la décision en tout cas devient urgente
sinon on peut augurer que les ennemis
des pigeons vont passer à l'action
les en mettant le bricolage et la
patience au service d'une haine
longtemps contenue les autres peut-être
employant les grands moyens et il est
des évocations tellement tories
[Musique]
en décalant premier grand prix
international de l'année comptant pour
le championnat du monde des conducteurs
défiguration de la victoire stirling
moss descend de sa voiture comme s'il
était déjà bac c'est bientôt le départ
que va donner louis chiron un
connaisseur
son parti c'est ce bolide rouge vert et
blanc entament la ronde qui va durer
près de trois heures dans les rues de la
ville une ronde de très pénible sous un
soleil de plomb sur un circuit très
tournante et beignets le même poster
jumeaux ce numéro 20 qui est en tête le
champion britannique au volant d'une
lotus pourtant moins rapide que les
ferrari donne un véritable récital de
pilotage
on n'avait pas vu mieux depuis lundi
on s'étonne encore aujourd'hui que
stirling moss n'ai jamais été champion
du monde alors qu'il est de loin le
meilleur de tous les pilotes de grand
prix
champion du monde il le sera peut-être
cette année en tout cas après sa
victoire à monte-carlo
tous les espoirs lui sont permis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rencontre au sommet du football français
au parc des princes 40000 spectateurs
entassés dans les tribunes transpirant
comme dans un bain turc attendent de ce
match un champion de france de fait le
vainqueur de la rencontre va prendre une
sérieuse option sur le titre 1961 pour
le moment le racing maillot blanc
culotte noire et monaco n'en sont qu'aux
toutes premières escarmouches locale
mais c'est monsieur l'arbitré accorde un
penalty à monaco quelle belle le manque
pour la plus grande joie des spectateurs
décidément sans pitié une fois n'est pas
coutume le public parisien soutien
dressing et c'est peut-être pour cela
que les joueurs de la capitale
fournissent leur meilleur match de la
saison
voilà comment ton amène un fort joli but
après un premier quart d'heure de jeu
plein de promesses se sont déjà presque
champion de france dans les gradins
monaco ne baisse pas les bras loin de là
ce qui donne encore beaucoup plus de
relief à la rencontre cette attaque de
l'ailier gauche carlier aurait peut-être
fait mouche si le crâne dégarni leur
démarche ne s'était trouvé sur la
trajectoire de la balle
elle revient dans le camp parisien cette
balle mais roger marché aussi et avec
lui toute la défense du racing
[Applaudissements]
on ne s'affole pas dans des tribunes
épreuve
[Applaudissements]
d'autant que la victoire du racing dont
les attaques sont plus tranchantes et
quasi certaine
on appuie au bon moment sur la caméra
pour fixer le second but petit exploit
technique de vente sam affolement dans
la défense monégasque
une joie qui est bien placé
[Applaudissements]
c'est maintenant le festival des joueurs
parisiens qui vont marquer un troisième
but et avec cette victoire le racing est
déjà presque champion de france
pour la conférence d'evian
un avion a amené à genève les membres de
la délégation fln conduite par monsieur
belkacem krim et qui comprend messieurs
boumendjel et ahmed francis qui
résultats le 3 toutes les tendances du
fln et à sa descente d'avion
monsieur belkacem krim a évoqué le sens
général des revendications effet l'être
quand nous avons eu l'occasion de le
déclarer
l'algérie veut accéder à la vie
internationale sans complexe avec le
désir sincère de coopérer avec tous les
peuples et d'apporter sa modeste
contribution au progrès humain
c'est dans une villa genevoise la villa
du bois davout transformée en camp
retranché et sévèrement gardés par
l'armée et la police helvétique que la
délégation fln a établi son quartier
général
[Musique]
c'est de là que le matin du samedi 20
mai les délégués se sont envolés à bord
de trois hélicoptères pour rejoindre
evian
[Musique]
evian l'hôtel du parc la police fait
toujours aussi bonne garde
monsieur louis joxe ministre d'état pour
les affaires d'algérie chef de la
délégation française arrive le premier
journalistes et caméras sont parqués à
distance respectueuse
la délégation fln pénètre à son tour à
l'hôtel du parc
nous ne verrons rien de plus mais en
même temps un grand fait ces produits la
france a ordonné en algérie un
cessez-le-feu unilatéral
du côté français les armes se taisent
sauf cas de légitime défense
conférence d'evian cessez-le-feu
français sommes-nous enfin en vue de
l'aboutissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hymne à l'heure de la feria les
vieilles arènes romaines sont comme
toujours en pareille occasion plein à
craquer nîmes est aujourd'hui en espagne
et voici antonio ordonne yes le beau
frère de dominique green qui lui donne à
l'investiture
l'alternative en langage tauromachique
depuis ordonniez c'est devenu son rival
certains disent sont égales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelles qualités faut-il pour être
torero le courage et le style le courage
ils sont beaucoup qui n'en manque pas le
style
il faut regarder hors d'agnès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le festival de cannes s'est terminée
comme il convient au cinéma sous une
pluie d'étoilés
la palme d'or du grand prix a été
attribué à deux films ex-aequo viridiana
de l'espagnol luis bunuel et une aussi
longue absence du français henri code
pin
en même temps le prix d'interprétation
féminine revenait à sophia loren pour
son rôle de l'acteur chara et le prix
d'interprétation masculine à anthony
perkins pour sa création d mais vous
brahms
c'est fini le rideau tombe pour m
[Musique]
distribution des prix également à paris
mais pour l'effort en littérature marie
morgane maurice genevoix jean bertoua
membres du jury ont salué la victoire du
lauréat du prix sève de la croix andré
langue que le maréchal juin à féliciter
pour son livre bagages à la consigne
la photographie elle a tenu salon à la
bibliothèque nationale ce qui a donné
l'occasion de constater que l'art du
portrait ne pêchait pas à l'origine par
ex et d'imagination
l'appareil mystère sacré ne bougeait pas
quant aux patients jeu d'attitude réduit
appuyé à droite appuyée à gauche ou
façon penseurs
[Musique]
il faut dire pourtant qu'avec nadar et
ses modèles théophile gautier eugène
delacroix et victor hugo à 50 et à 80
ans le portraitiste gagna ses lettres de
noblesse mais comme pour toulouse
lautrec le portrait est resté
généralement enlisé dans les vues
générales ainsi henri rochefort et sarah
bernhardt
aujourd'hui l'art du portrait à d'autres
ambitions
il interprète et l'on peut suivre à
travers les portraits qu'on fait d'un
même modèle 30 photographes différents
l'étonnante aventure d'un visage tantôt
lumineux est comme saisi par un étrange
ban pureté tantôt au contraire devenue
le reflet de force inquiétante
l'art du portrait
un salon chasse l'eau et c'est à n'en
pas douter avec avidité que les esprits
affamés de nouveautés se pencheront sur
ce bureau qu'on peut le plus aisément du
monde transformer en lit parfait pour
ses bourreaux de travail qui ne quittent
leurs dossiers qu journée sans cette
invention compte parmi les plus
vertigineuses du concours lépine de
cette année qui en offrent quelques
autres le clignotant rétractable pour
vélos matters par exemple ou encore
l'auto pédales d'un animaux extrêmement
commode et qui réhabilite loto à pédales
de nos enfants quant aux tâches les plus
tenaces
on peut désormais les supporter en toute
sérénité puisque dit on
rien ne résiste plus à l'action du super
rénovateurs
[Musique]
enfin une nouveauté qui réjouira tous
les pêcheurs la can a lancé qui projette
automatiquement la cuillère à 16 mètres
et qui permet de ne plus se soucier des
berges broussailleuse enfin
[Musique]
on songe aux trésors d'ingéniosité qu'il
fallait jusqu'ici déployé pour arriver à
lancer cette pauvre cuillère sans risque
et d'accrocher une branche au passage on
n'avait rien trouvé de mieux que le lens
fusée mais tout de même la méthode
sentait son bricole et puis il valait
mieux savoir nager
[Musique]
après traque la pentecôte
des milliers d'automobilistes ont repris
la route cette fois encore tous ne sont
pas revenus
or les accidents de la route non pas
pour cause qu'un hasard ou une
défaillance il y à aussi l'alcool mais
si l'ivresse caractérisé n'appelle aucun
commentaire il n'en va pas de même des
simples pause alcoolisées on ne se méfie
pas assez de l'agréable état d'euphorie
procuré par quelques modestes vers
[Musique]
l'alcool ainsi répandus dans le sang
provoque pourtant la perte de 30% de
l'acuité visuelle de 38% de l'acuité
auditive
[Musique]
il n'est jusqu'aux joyeux repas prise
innocemment même famille qu'il puisse
transformer une sortie dominicale en
voyage pour l'éternité
alors en prenant le volant méfiez-vous
du bien-être suspect que procure
l'alcool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces horizons ces rivières n'ont pas
changé mais non plus ses hommes de la
nouvelle guinée que dans son film le
ciel et la boue nous présente pierre
dominique gayssot ils sont dans leurs
parures et dans leur rythme dans leurs
usagers dans leur vie pareil à ce que
découvrit dans ses voyages le capitaine
cook qui fut grand découvreur dit
l'inconnu au temps où la terre et est
encore vaste et mystérieuse au son des
tambours sacrés plusieurs tribus se
réunissent aujourd'hui pour la grande
fête des esprits sur la berge les femmes
très habillée comme on le voit atteindre
les hommes qui mime les gestes du combat
qui chassera les démos
[Applaudissements]
c'est des mots les voici cinq jeunes
gens masqués de la tête aux pieds
personnifie les puissances mauvaise
qu'il faut chasser loin du village et
pas à pas la procession s'avance le long
du fleuve poussant devant elle les cinq
démos qui l'on ne saura pas ce qu'ils
sont devenus rites étranges sorti du
fond des temps
nous sommes revenus au premier âge du
mot à lyon en interne et de la finale du
championnat de france de rugby le toro
de fuego de supporter dacquois avaient
mis déjà le feu aux poudres
et pourtant ni les joueurs de dax ni
ceux de béziers à droite de l'écran
maillot légèrement plus clair que ceux
de leurs adversaires avaient besoin de
cela pour s'expliquer d'une manière
souvent explosives
le match peut se résumer en trois coups
de pied dans le ballon et une série
d'autres coups plus ou moins orthodoxes
distribués sans parcimonie premier coup
de pied dans le ballon
trois points pour les dacquois
[Applaudissements]
et
après cela on s'explique que chacun avec
son tempérament et selon son poids
une tonne et demie de muscles dans une
mêlée il faut bien ça explose de temps
en temps
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien le moment de sonner la charge
dans des tribus
[Musique]
puisqu'on ne peut attraper le ballon
autant se dépenser un peu en distribuant
quelques coups au hasard
il n'en mouraient pas tous mais tous
étaient frappés
[Musique]
enfin un second coup de pied dans le
ballon
en quoi pour désir les dacquois se
réveille il se rappelle tout à coup que
le bon rugby se joue à la main oui mais
que ne ferait on pas pour garder le
ballon sous le bras
tout de même il y a eu un grand moment
dans ce match ce moment le voilà ballon
pour béziers à cinq mètres de la ligne
de but de dax un admirable coup de pied
de l'âne au sein de ses coups de pied
comme on en donne à tous les 50 ans sur
un terrain de rugby
béziers mc 3 points de plus cet exploit
donne la victoire à béziers par six
autres
bruxelles à l'heure du championnat
d'europe des poids coq le belge cosmas
large parements blancs sur la culotte
réalise son rêve il rencontre le
champion d'europe de la catégorie le
britannique fred ighil roj
bientôt ce mince est tout de suite dans
le vif du sujet il fait déjà
connaissance avec le tapis
et pourquoi pas deux fois pendant son
adversaire seulement voilà frais des
guides rome ne s'est pas que pierre
cosmence récupère très vite
brad à son tour qu'il ne faut pas trop
rapidement vendre la peau de l'ours
maintenant vous êtes à égalité messieurs
pour celui d'entre vous qui tombera la
prochaine fois ce sera sûrement la bonne
vieille est à terre ça y est
[Applaudissements]
non pas encore ces deux boxeurs sont
extraordinaires ils se rendent coup pour
coup
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'y avait pas de gong le combat
était fini et l'on commence comme si
rien ne s'était passé
le résultat ne va plus tarder qu'il
réussit fondre encore ils voudraient
bien continuer son manager est plus sage
que lui il jette l'épongé
le britannique n'est plus qu'une poupée
désarticulée
le combat est terminé il a fallu une
offrande à pire cosmas pour devenir
champion d'europe
un rêve qu'il réalise à l'âge de 30 ans
[Musique]
c'est un peu le monde de l'avenir coffre
aux investigations des mordus de tous
âges
le 24e salon international de
l'aéronautique du bourget où trône le
bombardier américain b 58 qui reliait
new york à paris en 3h20 lindbergh
il y à 34 ans avait mis plus de trente
deux heures
à côté des maquettes d'appareils dont on
parlera mirage iv et super caravelle
l'aéronautique française fait étalage de
son écurie de fusée ces fusées toute
modeste quels sont tes moyens en tout
cas que la france est entrée dans la
cause
[Musique]
il reste bien entendu que la curiosité
conduira infailliblement à la vedette du
salon
la capsule mercury dans laquelle alan
shepard réaliser l'exploit qu'il a promu
au rang de second cosmonautes du monde
a paris le palais de chaillot a abrité
le 3e congrès mondial de la prévention
des risques professionnels
mille quatre cent cinquante délégués
représentant 52 nations sont venus se
pencher sur des problèmes qui
intéressent le monde du travail
ce que pose la sécurité des travailleurs
dans l'exercice de leur métier
[Musique]
à
la conférence d'evian suit jour par jour
son chemin n'a lésé l'hôtel du parc
ouvre régulièrement aux délégations son
salon hier sans histoire mais si l'on en
est encore qu'au prologue il n'en est
pas moins vrai que le banal salon
d'evian abrite aujourd'hui un dialogue
ce dialogue l'annnonce du cessez-le-feu
unilatéral ne l'a pas interrompu en
dépit d'une certaine mauvaise humeur
par contre elle a déclenché en algérie
un climat qui peut sembler nouveau il
semble qu'il y ait plus de monde sur les
plages les pique niques dans la forêt de
sidi ferruch avait été quelque peu
délaissé on n'y a trouvé cette semaine
comme une atmosphère de kermesse
[Musique]
dira-t-on qu'il y à une détente
c'est sans doute difficile mais les
affiches qu'on commence à voir partout
clame à tous les échos et même sur les
volets de la pharmacie de ferhat abbas à
sétif qu'un autre climat peut naître et
que la volonté de paix de la france est
évidente d'autant que cette volonté se
traduit par d'autres gestes en une
semaine
laliberté a été rendu à 2500 prisonniers
le chiffre sera porté à six mille dans
moins d'un mois
cette mesure n'était pas la preuve d'un
esprit qui pour faire une paix véritable
veut recréer la confiance c'est cette
volonté de paix traduite par ses gestes
et d'autre que 80 journalistes de tous
les horizons sont à les contrôler et
constaté l'opinion mondiale qui a
accueillies avec faveur les décisions du
gouvernement français que aussi bien
raisonner sur des faits contrôlée corps
ont vu en effet ces journalistes c'est
reporter ses yeux dont le métier de voir
pour d'autres ils auront vu dans des
rues animées des foules qui vont à leur
affaire des cinémas plein des cafés pezi
il ne s'agit pas de nier les atteintes à
il y en a toujours
mais les arbres ne peuvent toujours
cacher la forêt et rien ne peut plus
dissimuler que l'algérie prend un
nouveau visage
[Musique]
ces faits paris sans doute mais c'était
la france aussi qui faisait dans le
printemps des champs elysées le plus
beau des accueils au roi baudouin et à
la reine fabiola de belgique
le général de gaulle était allé vais
recevoir à leur descente d'avion et dans
le bruit des acclamations ou paris
exprimé son amitié se retrouve l écho de
la visite qu'avait fait voici 51 ans
le roi albert et la reine elizabeth le
jeune couple royal renouvelle à l'elysée
la chaîne des temps et il l'a renouait
avec cette précieuse qualité qu'est la
grâce de la jeunesse si protocolaire
qu'elle fut cette visite était une
visite d'amis et l'histoire de france
est trop proche de l'histoire de
belgique pour que le louvre ne fut pas
invité lui aussi à accueillir le roi
baudouin et la reine qui pour ce soir la
porte et le diadème de la reine astrid
[Musique]
les visiteurs ceva dès le lendemain vers
un autre séjour royal fontainebleau qui
vit tourner aussi quelques-unes des plus
grandes pages de l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le public parisien étaient nombreux le
soir aux portes de l'opéra pour voir
passer le jeune souverain et la reine
fabiola dont le sourire et la simplicité
ont déjà fait sa conquête
[Musique]
resplendissante soirée où après la
présentation des artistes et du corps de
ballet le plus choisi des publics saluer
dans la loge centrale l'un des plus
sympathiques parmi les couples salaires
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain au château de versailles le
roi baudouin était seule la reine
atteinte d'une légère maladie n'avait pu
l'accompagner dans cette visite au plus
somptueux des règnes français ce soir
comme voici 200 ans
le palace animèrent vivaient autour de
visages célèbres et de nos glorieux et
c'est dans ce cadre impérissable que
s'achevait la visite des souverains
belges
la france avait pu en si peu de jours
leur offrir trois palais prestigieux le
louvre fontainebleau versailles la
grandeur de son histoire avec la ferveur
de son amitié
avant son départ pour paris où il allait
rencontrer le général de gaulle le
président kennedy avait dit je vais en
france pour contribuer aux relations
étroites qui doivent permettre de
sauvegarder la cause de la liberté
et dès le premier moment on pouvait
penser que ces deux hommes qui
représentent chacun des intérêts
différents parfois mais un esprit commun
pouvait bâtir une oeuvre utile à la
peine tout de suite aussi on avait pu
sentir la chaleur de la rencontre la
population parisienne le long du
parcours ne ménageait pas ses
applaudissements à ce duo illustres qui
porte aujourd'hui avec le destin de deux
grandes nations
une part du sort du monde
et dès l'arrivée à l'elysée qu'une armée
de photographes a siégé sans d'ailleurs
marquée des résultats spectaculaires
après cette photo du perron devenu
classique mais à laquelle le sourire de
jacqueline kennedy apportait un éclat
nouveau les entretiens prévus entre les
deux hommes d'état commencé seul à seul
les deux hommes allaient après
l'éviction des photographes aborder
l'examen des dossiers d'une époque
périlleuse
[Musique]
madame jacqueline kennedy accompagnée de
madame de gaulle devait dans l'après
midi aller visiter l'école de
puériculture fondé en 1919
grâce à la croix rouge américaine devant
ses petits enfants français jacqueline
kennedy n'a t'elle pas penser qu'elles
appartenaient un peu à cette grande
famille nationale où la famille bouvier
la sienne a toujours de profondes
racines
à ce moment les deux présidents
remontait sous la pluie les
champs-elysées pour aller faire devant
la tombe de l'inconnue le geste de piété
traditionnel mais ce geste était dans la
circonstance plus large et plus vrai
n'est ce pas à versailles qu'est née
l'indépendance américaine
c'est au nom de l'amitié celle les ce
jour-là que le président kennedy a signé
le livre d'or et kennedy n'at-il pas dit
lui même
la france notre plus vieil ami
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]